- Bavure ou frappe délib
Pour la première fois dans
le conflit ukrainien, unayays
membre de l'OTAN a été frappé.
En Pologne, à la fr
ukrainienne, deux explosions,
dont l'une a détru u une ferme
et tué deux personnes.
Missile, débris
des roquettes, des bombes?
Et surtout qui a tiré?
Les conséquences pourraient être
très graves puisque l'article 5
stipule que toute agression
sur un état membre déclencrarait
une riposte de l'ensemble
La Pologne prend l'affaire
au sérieux. Le président,
Andrzej Duda, dit qu'il réagit
ca
qu'il n'y avait pas encore
de preuves sur q a a tiré
sur le village polonais.
Il s'est entretenu avec le
président Bideetet le secrétaire
général de l'OTAN sur le recours
possible à l'article 4
une consultation de tous
les membs s sur la situation.
Mais pour le président
Zelensky, il ne fait aucun doute
que les Russes sont coupables.
En Ukra
d'alerte de la défense
antiaérienne ont retenti en
après-midi, et quelques minutes
plus tard, des explosions
à Kiev, Lviv, à l'ouest,
etet Kharkiv, au nord-est.
Les missiles ont été tirés
la région de Rostov, et aussi
depuis la mer Noire, selon
le ministère de la Défense, qui
affirme
70 ont été interceptés.
C'est e e des frappes les plus
massives de l'armée russe,
tr
de la ville stratégique
de Kherson et sa région. d d d s
résidentielsntnt été touchés,
au moins deux personnes sont
décédées,
la capitale, Vitaly Klitschko.
Les ssssiles ont endommagé
surtout les réseaux
la situation critique
dadans tout le pays.
Dans la capitale, au moins
sans électricité, et l'opérateur
national a déclenché des
coupures de courant d'urgence
dans toute l'Ukraine
Des explosions se sont fait
entendre à Lviv, et on pouvait
en voir la fumée depuis le
centre-ville. Les habita r r r ,
une partie de la ville est
restée sans électricité.
Lviv se trouve non loin de la
Pologne, qui, po, , , , , , , ,.
Ici Jean-Michel Leprince,
Radio-Canada, Montréa